overseas now the senate confirmed an
ambassador to ukraine for the first time
in three years last night and while that
might be an important symbol of support
for that embattled country president
biden's meeting with the leaders of
finland and sweden today represents
international resistance against russia
both countries have applied to join nato
in part to protect against russian
aggression
the timing is also interesting it comes
as a russian soldier pleaded guilty to
war crimes this is a first in the
ukrainian capital city of kiev he had
been accused of killing a 62 year old
man and as debra patter reports it's all
part of ukraine's effort to prove that
vladimir putin's army has been targeting
civilians
a mother's naked grief
and a wife's anguished tears
in malaya rohan this family has gathered
to bury the man they love
for a second time
god why did you take my son wells 83
year old tamara
just two days earlier war crimes
prosecutors came to ludmilla yorchenko's
home to exhume her husband's body they
are building a case to bring the
perpetrators to justice
mikhail chenko was killed when russian
troops deliberately aimed their tanks at
his village
their humble backyard now a crime scene
ludmilla shows investigators where
mikhail laid dying after both his legs
were blown off
ludmilla's husband came out to feed the
animals when he was hit by shrapnel you
see some of it there still lying on the
ground and later they buried him here in
the shallow grave
leading the field team alexander ilenkov
who swapped his business suit for body
armor we are civil prosecutors but we
are on war
and we
we are doing our job
and he's busy today is exclusion the
14th one this month
it's grim work but beneath that blanket
is the love of lude miller's life
he was such a big wonderful man we lived
together for nearly 30 years she sobs i
just can't accept that he's dead
mikhail's body was taken for forensic
examination now it's come home
a final caress from ludmilla
and the tormented cries of his mother
who simply cannot let go
for cbs mornings deborah patter malaya
rohan ukraine